it's become an
all familiar sight at delhi's largest
hindu crematorium
a section carved out just for kovic
deaths
last rites under the shadow of the virus
a distant
and hurried farewell for the family of a
65 year old man
who succumbed to the pandemic all
deprived
of a traditional ritual
it's a similar scene in mumbai india's
commercial capital
and the worst affected city in the
country
putting themselves at risk this
organization
went to hospital mortuaries across the
city
picking up the abandoned providing some
dignity
to more than eight hundred dead till now
um
foreign
has been the epicenter for a while
[Music]
social distancing in hygienic living
conditions
is a privilege most cannot afford
at the sci hospital in dharavi these
kovit patients
are on amend but many have not been that
lucky
this main district hospital in bihar one
of the poorest states has
telling signs of government apathy
ward after ward is bereft of basic
medical equipment
patients are left on their own
rupes kumar came here with breathing
problems
he was attached to a device that doesn't
work
and has been waiting for assistance
ppe's and biomedical waste lie discarded
in the open
as pigs roam free inside the hospital
complex
scavenging on this waste a severe
pandemic
will collapse the already struggling
public health structure
ravaging its poor never lazarus
sky news delhi